When you think of Australia, you might think of kangaroos,
koalas or premium Australian beer, like Foster's lager. Sorry,
Aussies.
But another thing you might think of is that distinct Australian way or ways of
speaking English,
the story of Australian English begins with the arrival of European settlers in
Australia in 1788,
convicts from Britain and Ireland were exiled to new South Wales,
which was founded as an overseas penal colony.
They weren't all ruthless criminals, mind you.
Many of them were only guilty of theft and some of them were children over
160,000 convicts were sent there over the next 80 years,
mainly working class people from the major cities of England,
as well as Scotland, Wales, and Ireland.
There were also many free settlers who joined them.
The significance of this is that people speaking different English dialects from
all over Britain and Ireland were essentially thrown together in the same place
where they had to learn to understand one another.
Remember back then there was no radio or television to familiarize people with
different accents in order to understand each other. Well,
they had to learn to speak in a way that was less regional.
This resulted in dialect leveling dialectal variations were removed from their
speech.
You could say that the core of Australian English is a compromise between the
various regional dialects of Britain and Ireland. And since then,
Australian English has developed its own features, words, and expressions.
It has also been influenced by additional waves of immigration.
Since the days of the penal colony ended.
There are basically three varieties of Australian English, broad general,
and cultivated Australian English.
They essentially form an accent continuum with the speaker's accent, depending,
mostly on whether they grew up in a rural area or an urban area.
There are socioeconomic background and perhaps the kind of subculture they
identify with broad Australian English has the features that people outside of
Australia tend to associate with Australian English. You know,
when they think of Steve Irwin, the crocodile Hunter,
or maybe Paul Hogan and crocodile Dundee, and just a word of warning strains,
never say this, throw another shrimp on the Barbie,
unless they're taking the out of you.
Plaguing the PIs is an expression used in Britain and Australia.
That means to make fun of someone or mess with them.
It's not used in North American English, I'm Canadian. And I sometimes use it,
but that's because I've picked it up from some Aussie friends of mine.
Here are a few examples of broad Australian English that you'll probably only
hear in rural areas or maybe amongst older people or amongst, um,
is it politically correct to say Ockers and bogans?
And, uh, does that mean no? Nah, yeah.
Women are sometimes referred to as Sheilas.
Somehow that one particular name Sheila came to represent women in general.
For example, if I say, Hey man, where's Liam in theory, I might get this reply.
Yeah, he's over the Avenue. Chat with some Sheila strewth,
she's a bit of a loca. Struth.
Is used as an to show surprise.
It actually originated in the UK and is a contraction of God's truth.
But now it's used much more in Australia Struth. Well,
at least in broad Australian English, a similar word is Crocky.
This is also used as an interjection to show surprise. But again,
this is limited to broad Australian English,
unless someone's taken the plaguing,
the pice cultivated Australian English is spoken by less than 10% of Aussies.
Non Aussies might mistake it for British received pronunciation.
It has many fewer,
obviously Australian features general Australian English is spoken by the
majority of Aussies. And as somewhere between the two,
these different varieties of Australian English are not regional.
For the most part.
It's hard to tell the difference between people from Brisbane, Melbourne,
Sydney, and other cities based on their accents.
Some people also argue that there's a fourth accent,
the accent of the outer suburbs of major cities,
which developed among communities that have immigrated to Australia since the
second world war,
this kind of accent is often perceived as an immigrant accent though.
It's spoken among the children and grandchildren of immigrants and crosses
ethnic boundaries in those neighborhoods.
Most of the examples after this point in the video will be more or less general
Australian English spelling,
Australian English normally follows British spelling conventions rather than
American. That means in words like organize and authorize,
the ISC spelling is normally preferred to the Izod. IE spelling,
words like color and flavor are spelled with O U R rather than,
or words like center and liter are spelled with R E rather than ER,
and so on.
The reason why American English uses different spellings from British English is
because of Noah Webster whose dictionary published in 1828,
chose certain variant spellings to be the American ones in order to make
American English distinct.
This was specific to the U S so it didn't affect Australia. Pronunciation,
Australian accents are Arliss accents or non rhotic accents,
meaning that the R sound is not pronounced at the end of a syllable or word,
unless there's a word beginning with a vowel after it.
This is the same as in most accents of England. For example,
K compare that to my rhotic Canadian accent care care.
I don't care. I don't care different.
The sense of English are mainly distinguished by differences in vowels.
And that's the case with Australian English. For instance,
Aussie English basically has two a sounds, ah, and ah,
some words are pronounced with, ah,
in both Australian and North American English, for example,
cat cat nap, nap.
But other words that I would pronounce with an sound are often pronounced
differently with a long, ah, in Australian English. For example, math,
both laugh, laugh.
This is because of a split that occurred in the early modern English vowel app
in Southern England. The sound began to change to a long OSS out as in father,
before certain sounds. This is referred to as broad a,
this change made its way to Australia,
but the vowel became a central vowel rather than a back vowel, ah, path,
rather than the British word boss.
This distinction is not used across the board in Australia, in English though.
It has the most influence in South Australia.
The most noticeable feature of Australian English pronunciation is probably its
diphthongs and Australian greeting. I'm sure you've heard is.
Good. Or.
It's really only Aussies who use this as a greeting. But if I tried to say it,
it would sound like good day, mate, listen to the difference in the diphthongs.
The vowel sounds good.
Good. I mate, mate.
The word day is not to be confused with the word die, die.
The equivalent of American and British I is I for example,
price.
Price, hide, hide.
There's also a different Australian pronunciation of the diff long that I would
pronounce as owl, Australian say something like out.
How, how downtown downtown.
There's also a diphthong that I pronounce as oil Australian say something more
like oily boy, boy, the Aussie sound is less open.
Another is the diphthong O as in boat, Australian say,
but there are some characteristic features of intonation in Australian
English. One such feature is called high rising terminal.
This means that Australians often say clauses within a statement with intonation
that rises at the end,
like a yes or no question and North American or British English.
In the following example, you can hear it at the end of the first clause.
Uh, met robo down the pock. Um,
we met up with a couple of mates and uh, played a bit of footy.
This kind of intonation is standard in Australia. These days,
you might hear it sometimes in North America and the UK as well though.
A lot of people find it annoying.
You might hear it referred to as uptalk vocabulary while the vast,
vast majority of Australian English vocabulary is the same as another varieties.
It does have its own word preferences,
as well as words and expressions that are uniquely Ozzie.
The most famous Ozzy phrase just might be good. I might, as we heard before,
just like in the UK, Ozzy is often referred to friends as mates, as in the UK,
the word mate is used in contexts where North Americans would say friend,
or maybe man when addressing someone casually.
But unlike in the UK in Australia,
mate is not limited to casual situations or to your peers.
You can use it with older people or people with a higher rank or position than
you. This reflects the overwhelmingly casual nature of Aussies and the way they
communicate to inquire about someone's wellbeing.
You might hear the mask as a North American. This sounds strange to my years,
we ask how's it going rather than how are you going? Similarly,
when you apologize and Ozzy might say, you're right,
rather than that's all right,
which is what I would say the first time I heard this, I was confused. Like,
why are you telling me I'm all right.
Another expression that's likely to confuse us North Americans is who is
she referring to? Well, no one it's referring to the situation.
I would say, it'll be all right, or it'll be fine.
When Aussies want to get someone's attention, you might hear them say,
I would say, Hey instead, amen.
Third income. Or just think of this expression means genuine, honest, or true.
It can also be used as a question income for real.
And it can be used as an adjective to describe someone he's a fading, Moz.
This is like saying he's a true Ozzie.
I've come across a couple of possible etymologies of this expression.
One of them States that it comes from a dialectal word of England, dinkum,
meaning hard work. Another etymology States that it comes from Cantonese,
which was spoken by prospectors in the early goldmines Dean gum,
meaning real gold though.
I tend to think the first etymology is the correct one.
Remember that sentence from a moment ago, he's a fading Moz. Well,
we could expand that a little.
He's a fed income, true blue Aussie mate.
I might say he's a real genuine Ozzie, true blue.
This phrase is kind of like fair dinkum, meaning true as in genuine,
but also has the meaning of loyal and to all the people with that positive
personality trait. I say good on ya. Good on you is what Ozzy say.
When they want to show they're impressed or they respect something good you've
done. I would probably say nice work or good job from what I understand.
Good Anya comes from high Burno English.
That is Irish English note that good on you can be used both sincerely and
sarcastically. For example,
let's say I'm bragging about how much of a pimp I am and how I scored last
night. You're.
Out. I might good on you when.
You say thanks and Aussie might reply with no worries,
which is like saying no problem or don't worry about it.
No worries can also be used in response to an apology.
No worries is a way of life in Australia and something of a national motto.
Aussies tend to be lighthearted and not take things too seriously.
But if you're one of those people who tends to complain or sulk,
or if you're easily offended, you might be called a soak or as an adjective.
Soki Aussies love to use diminutive words,
special forms of words that show endearment.
This is usually done through shortening a word and adding a special suffix to
it. Afternoon becomes this afternoon becomes the Saba
or Saba BBQ becomes Bobby mosquito becomes
Muzzy. Football becomes footy. Cigarette becomes Siggy.
Sandwich becomes Sanger.
Postman becomes posty garbage man becomes GABA.
Christmas becomes Chrissy chocolate biscuit,
Chucky Beaky surface station becomes server and that's for a service station,
meaning a gas station or a petrol station McDonald's becomes
MCAS. And this is ubiquitous throughout Australia.
Isolation becomes also as in quarantine,
due to the 19 [inaudible].
There were also some words in Aussie English that originates in Aboriginal
languages of Australia.
One example you might hear in particular in broad Australian English is hard
yakka, which means hard work. Yakka is a word from the yoga language,
which used to be spoken in the Brisbane region.
This word made its way into Australian English through the English based pigeon
language that was originally used between European settlers and aboriginals that
pigeon later developed into Australian Creole,
which is still spoken by around 20,000 people today in the Northern territory,
there are some other well-known nouns that represent specific things in the
Australian environment like Dinga or glimmering,
which come from the extinct Dharug language,
which used to be spoken in the Sydney area.
Australian English is largely the same as other varieties of English,
but with their own accents,
vocabulary and attitude that reflect the laid back nature of Aussies,
endearing and friendly are two words that come to mind when I think of Aussies
and their way of speaking English. Oh,
one final feature of Australian English that we can get into is they're
extremely liberal use of the word though.
YouTube might ban me if I talk about that.
So maybe I should just move on to the question of the day for speakers of Aussie
English.
I'm sure there are heaps of Ozzy words and expressions that I didn't have time
to mention in the video. So what other ones would you like to add?
Write them in the comments down below. And this is the part of the video.
When I say thanks to my Patrion patrons,
especially it might talk to your patrons whose names appear on the screen,
becoming a member on Patrion gives you various benefits like early releases
ad-free and promotion,
free videos and access to a patrons only online community. Check out
patrion.com/lang focus for more information and to everyone.
Thank you for watching and have a good one.